Jackie the state of Texas is once again
taking matters into its own hands
passing a law which makes it a State
Crime to cross the southern border
illegally that means police in Texas
have the ability to arrest people
suspected of entering the country
illegally civil rights groups are
already suing over the three-day old law
let's bring in Texas lieutenant governor
Dan Patrick lieutenant governor good to
have you with us so the White House
other Democrats immigration activists
they're they're all complaining long and
loud about this new law listen to what
Karine jeanpierre said at the last White
House
briefing this is an extreme law that
will not and does not uh make the
communities in Texas safer it just
doesn't this is certainly um uh Extreme
as we see it and it is incredibly
unfortunate but this is what we see from
particular Republicans trying to
dehumanize a group of people who are
coming here or some of them trying to uh
migrate here uh and and they're putting
them In Harm's Way they're putting them
M hars away uh lieutenant governor what
do you say in response to
that I'm tired of her lies John I'm
tired of this administration's lies um
they are saying just the opposite of
what's Happening they're the ones that
have a policy that is seeing Americans
killed by fentanyl they're the ones who
are seeing terrorists cross over our
border we know we've arrested about 300
they're the ones that are responsible
for peing people drowning in the river
they're the ones responsible for women
being raped across the border illegally
they're the ones responsible for all of
this and so we passed a law and in Texas
the lieutenant governor is the president
of the Senate I oversee it I was very
involved in writing this bill with the
Senators and the governor's office so I
know it well and we've had enough so
we're saying that we are being invaded
John you know our Founders said you know
an invasion by an army well the Army
we're facing is not the Mexican Army
although the Mexican president is doing
nothing to to stem this tide the Army
are the cartels and so we're saying we
have a right
to to grab people who cross the border
illegally arrest them uh give them the
choice of prison or going back home and
so we arrest them we get their
fingerprints we get their photographs we
do the background checks a magistrate
says you got a choice go to jail or go
home and if you go home and try to come
back again and we catch you the jail
term is going to even be longer we're we
think we'll win at the Supreme Court
because we're being invaded and we have
a right to protect the lives of Texas
and American citizens let me just add a
little bit of context uh to that uh
because the federal government says we
have the sole jurisdiction over the
Border but Governor Abbott and you are
citing article one section 10 of the
Constitution which says quote no State
shall without the consent of Congress
lay any duty of tonnage keep troops or
ships of war in time of Peace enter into
any agreement or contact with another
state or with a foreign power or engage
in war unless actually invaded or in
such imminent danger as will not admit
of delay the governor a couple of months
ago declared this to be Invasion with a
thousand or more Goda ways every day we
have no idea about them running across
the border and into this country that
would appear to be a clear National
Security risk then That's the basis you
say under which you're enacting this
law yeah yeah John look we believe in
the Constitution more than the president
of the United States does but our
Founders never envisioned a president
who would allow us to be invaded by
opening our borders to millions of
people when we say 8 million people have
come here in their first three years of
the Biden presidency that's the ones
we've apprehended if you get one out of
two that's 16 million people John we are
being overrun everyone knows it from
from mcgallen Texas to New York City to
Chicago everybody knows it this
President is cold-hearted he doesn't
care about what's happening to American
citizens or those coming here this is
this is something our Founders never
anticipated they never thought we'd be
invaded by civilians and a drug cartel
behind them that's as organized and as
powerful even maybe more so than the
Mexican Army so we've got to take this
stand we're willing to go to the Supreme
Court and say this is not what our
Founders Envision because this PR and by
the way the reason there 300,000 we're
going to break a record in December he
knows he's going to be out of office
this time next year he knows the
Democrats are going to go down and he's
trying to stuff every person he can into
this country eventually so that they get
citizenship and a right to vote they're
already John 8 million people who have
crossed the border that would be enough
to be the 13th largest state in the
country today if they were all in one
state yeah 300,000 what a staggering
number I want to ask you very quickly
about this as well because the Texas
state of Texas has had to take matters
into its own hands again Chicago put
restrictions on buses that were bringing
migrants from Texas to that City so now
you're flying them in why you bet you
bet because we need to move them on to
these blue cities and these blue States
you know these quote we're sanctuaries
come and come and be here well until
they came look we we're we have I passed
a bill that ban Sanctuary cities in
Texas but these other cities uh in these
blue States said no come here well now
they're here they don't want them
they're sending them elsewhere we want
to put pressure on Blue States but this
President is so bad not only doesn't he
care about a red State like Texas who
has a Target on our back from his
administration he doesn't even care
about the blue states he doesn't care
what's happening to New York City he
doesn't care about Chicago he doesn't
care about anybody this is a policy that
I said is designed to help take over
this country long term and these people
are coming here most of them if they got
to a court in a short time they would
not be given Asylum because they're
mostly single adult uh males that are
coming in they would be sent back almost
everyone who goes to court gets sent
back but these people they get a trial
date for 58 10 years from now this is
this is um we're going to put them on
planes we're going to put them on trains
we're going to put them on buses we're
going to do whatever we can we're going
to get them out of Texas I want to send
them all to Martha's Vineyard I want to
send them all to Delaware and raob I
want to send them all to where they
start feeling the pain that our citizens
feel on the border and across Texas
every day yeah that that notice that
bill maluan saw that notice to appear uh
which I think was January 28th 2031 I
mean that was something well uh we do
know that it's a joke it's a joke we do
know that the Secretary of State and the
DHS secretary are going to meet with
Mexico's president in the days ahead
we'll see if anything comes to it but
they do seem to be getting the message
in a way yeah all right danrick of the
great myc good to see you again thank
you thank you John Merry Christmas I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian Kil and I'm me Ley
Airhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis